[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Полтавщина,
Опішне]
Я пов'язаний з глиною ще з дитинства.
[Василь Омеляненко
Гончар]
Я нащадок, діди займалися вдома.
Батько займався обпаленням глини.
[Микола Варвинський
Гончар]
Гончар може сісти і показати,
[Олександр Шкурпела
Гончар]
який повинен мати вигляд виріб.
Століттями гончари своєю роботою
заробляли на хліб.
[Євдокія Варвинська
Майстриня гончарного ремесла]
Тому ми і називаємо іноді
нашу місцевість Гончарівкою.
Колись тут у кожному дворі був гончар.
Діди і прадіди — всі робили.
Глину довбали і привозили возами.
Дуже важка робота.
Сушиться.
Я закінчив вісім класів.
Вступив до училища.
Це був філіал при опішнянському
заводі художників.
У третьому цеху заводу працювала моя мати.
Тому я до неї пішов.
Тоді вже було кілька вільних гончарних кіл.
Сідав за один з них і до 17 години тренувався.
А ще, якщо мати давала пляшку дядькові,
вони вип'ють по сто грамів
і тоді направляли мене на «шлях істини».
Так і вчився.
Були спеціалісти, які робили
просто чудові роботи.
Але були і такі, які робили просте —
глечик, макітру...
І вони більш нічого і не старалися робити.
Мені завжди хотілося робити щось творче і гарне.
Не хотілося робити лише глечики,
не хотілося простої роботи,
а навпаки — щось складніше,
цікавіше і гарніше.
Найкраща зарплата була на заводі кераміки.
Складно було влаштуватися туди на роботу.
Вироби відправлялися до Англії, Канади...
Зараз завод закритий, але люди залишилися.
В Опішні роблять і сварщиками,
це люди, які пропрацювали 20 років гончарами.
Власне, вони пам'ятають і знають багато.
Ми готуємо глину від осені,
щоб взимку вона вже була підготована.
Біля 4-7 тонн.
Проте все одно,
коли дістаєш треба її перекачувати.
Це декілька сортів глини.
А ще вона може підсохнути у погребі
і так відразу гончарувати не вийде.
Колись, ще при Союзі, купив на заводі глину.
Багато, з пів тони.
Зробив тарілки, такі великі на стіну.
З 50 штук вийшла одна.
Відтоді я знаю, що треба
власноруч підготувати глину.
Де, як і для якого виробу.
Ось я скачав глину.
Це називається «головка».
Треба примазати [гончарне коло]
трішки глиною, щоб не впала.
І зараз буду гончарувати глечики.
Старший син ліпить тарілки —
аж самому хочеться.
Це продовження мене,
моїх рукк, моїх думок.
Колись на заводі в одній кімнаті
сиділо багато хороших майстрів.
Кожен старався зробити краще від іншого,
тому вироби виходили дуже гарні.
Майстерності треба вчитися протягом
усього життя — але може і не вистачити.
Коли мені було 9 років,
ми жили у квартирі.
Одного разу я побачив у сусіда
на столі іграшку —  півника.
Після цього я попросив мати
принести глини.
Вона дістала глину
і ми з братом почали ліпити свистунів.
Спершу півники  виходили поганенькі,
строкаті, нерівні.
Поналіплювали ми тих півників.
Це був 1934 рік, дуже раділи з того,
що зробили півників.
Продовжували цим займатися,
навчилися дуже добре робити.
Продовжували цю справу.
Можна сказати, що талант, який мені дістався,
я перетворив на глину.
Батьки не займалися гончарством,
а я пов'язав своє життя з глиною назавжди.
Зараз я ліплю свистунів, підсвічники, куманці.
Усе роблю.
Найголовніше: турбуватися про свій виріб,
адже робочий процес подібний
до народження чогось нового.
Робота з глиною допомогла мені
пережити втрату жінки,
іноді я ніби спілкуюся з виробами.
«Де ти будеш завтра, може, тебе розіб'ють,
а, може, ти будеш у печі пектися...»
Це для мене, ніби друге життя.
Я брав участь у багатьох виставках:
у Болгарії, Німеччині, колишній Югославії,
Норвегії, Англії, Китаї і Ізраїлі та США.
У США був двічі: у Чикаго і Сан-Франциско.
У мене є багато учнів
з Києва, Полтави, Сум.
Якщо ти не вмієш поводитися з глиною,
так вона ніби з тебе сміється, знущається,
що ти не в змозі її подолати.
Для мене це наче жива істота.
Ось шматок глини лежить
і я можу народити новий виріб.
Надати йому риси — характерний свист.
Лише розмовляти не може.
Я так звик до глини,
що не можу жити без неї.
Вона мене підтримує.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Дмитро Охріменко, Павло Пашко]
[Продюсерки
Наталя Панченко, Наталя Курсик]
[Редакторка відео
Карина Пілюгіна]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажер
Олексій Собчук]
[Музика
Гапочка, Endless]
[Субтитрувальник
Владислав Цовма]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]